[Music]
rebel nell is a social enterprise that
exists in detroit michigan we exist to
employ educate and empower women who are
transitioning out of homeless shelter
living and how we do that is we make
jewelry out of graffiti once it crumbles
off the walls
i was living in detroit right next door
to a well-known shelter and i felt this
this desire to do something for my
neighbors
what if we could provide employment as
well as all the tools they need so they
don't end up back in the shelter so we
thought okay let's make a product that's
detroit centric that we could sell
and then one day i just went for a
morning run and i saw
a small little piece of what looked like
paper that had fallen on the ground
and i thought oh that's kind of cool i
wonder what we could do with this
the rest is history
turning trash into something beautiful
i compare it to my life
at one point i felt like that graffiti
that was laying on the ground
i've been through so many traumatic
situations
and
i've grown to something
beautiful
never in a million years i thought i
would be making jury
[Music]
after the graffiti has fallen off of the
wall it has to be processed to reveal
all the different colors
we cut out different shapes and sizes
whatever speaks to us
because of my creative ability
a lot of people are carrying around a
small piece of my city
i think rebel nell's impact starts with
the individual encouraging them to
believe in themselves again we actually
graduate women to jobs that are more in
line with their dreams their visions
their career goals that's really what
inspired me to do it
and these women are my neighbors
you know i believe that you know rising
tide rises all boats
[Music]
you